hey what's up my name's samuel leeds i'm
a property investor and in this video
i'm going to be giving you all my top
tips around property investment in the
form
of answering your property investment
questions so
last week a whole bunch of people were
asking me questions around property
investment
right now straight answers straight
questions
let's do this let's see what we've got
by the way if you like my videos please
do smash the like button
also subscribe and while i'm answering
these questions here's what i want you
to do if you're watching this right now
i want you to comment your questions in
the description
in the comment box below and i'm going
to be answering your questions in the
comment box
next week on sunday at 7 p.m so get
questioning get questioning your
questioning
let's see what we got amy amy says hey
sammy i'm 27 me my partner have saved up
and bought a small studio flat out right
which we are now renting out if we keep
saving until this time next year
we could have enough to buy another one
outright which would secure us
cash flow we still live at home with
parents i really want to generate an
income each month through property not
sure if we should buy the next one
outright or do buy to let
my partner wants to do buy to let but
i'm not sure will we be able to make a
decent enough profit on buy to let
would we even get accepted considering
we don't have our own mortgage yet
what are the pros and cons of both would
love to know your view on this
amy you are a very very good
saver the fact that you're able to save
up so much cash you can just buy a
property out right now you're saving a
bit of cash again buying a property
outright
respect props to you for that however
it's going to take you a very very very
long time doing that
to get enough cash flow to be able to
become financially independent
my advice would be to 100
get a buy to let mortgage use that cash
instead of buying one property
to buy multiple properties see if you've
got 200 000 pounds
cash you can buy one house for 200 000
pounds cash
or you can buy four or five properties
for two hundred thousand pounds
but get a loan to value on the property
and then you own more houses you're
benefiting from more capital
appreciation
and you're getting four or five lots of
rent instead of one lot of rent
it just makes sense we call that good
debt so i would
definitely recommend you get a mortgage
and you should be able to get a mortgage
because it's a buy to let mortgage
so they don't care about your income
they care about the property you already
own a property
outright so you shouldn't have any
issues speak to a
mortgage advisor do not speak to your
bank if you speak to your bank they're
just going to tell you
what they can give you if you speak to a
mortgage broker or mortgage advisor
they're going to look at all the
different lenders and they're going to
give you the best rates and the best
option for you great question if you're
enjoying this
smash the like button amy if you're
watching this smash the like button as
well and let me know that you uh
you enjoyed my answer or not all right
dean dean
says as a newbie when going out to view
houses
what do you look for and how do you know
if it's a good deal to package
if it's in good condition with a high
rent rate and demand is then something
you would sell on once you calculate the
expected roi
dean if you're looking to package and
sell a deal how do you know if the deal
is good
you ask investors what they're looking
for then you go find what they're
looking for
that's it so you might think it's a
great deal
20 below market value it's wonderful but
your investors might not be interested
in that they might just want high cash
flow
or you might think oh this is such a
nice it's a hmo
in birmingham but they might not be
looking for that so you've got to go and
speak to investors
and you're going to say hey what are you
looking to buy they'll tell you what
they're looking to buy
and ask them if i can find something
suitable would you be in a position
where you can pay me a fee
then go find those types of deals that's
it all right ben
says is it possible to succeed in
property as an introvert
ben absolutely property business is a
people business
and a numbers game it's all about
numbers it's all about people it's not
actually about property
and if you're an introvert in fact a lot
of introverts are very good one-on-one
and i might do youtube videos and be
like hey everybody but
generally speaking as a property
investor you don't need to be able to do
that you just need to be able to have
conversations
you need to listen to people and
a hundred percent many of my students
are introverts so
absolutely yes go kick some ass you
introverted ninja
ronan just wondering how you know an
area has a demand for hmo
because you look on spareroom.com and
you see who's looking
in the area to rent rooms because you
speak to hmm management companies
because you find other investors who've
got hmos you ask them how the market's
going
due diligence is king connor morehouse
samuel i'm 18 i was putting money into
my lifetime
isaf for my first home and then got into
property afterwards but i feel like it's
smarter to just work and save to build a
property portfolio instead while i can
save more at the family home
maybe what do you think i think you're
right connor
i think lifetime ices suck i think help
to buy
sucks it's not helped to buy its help to
sell for the developer lifetime issue is
all about keeping you in a broke poverty
mindset mentality
to work 40 years for 40 hours a week to
retire on 40
of what you couldn't afford to live on
in the first place what do i mean by
that
lifetime isa here's why it sucks so bad
because
firstly you can only put up to a
thousand pounds a year
i mean that's from memory i don't know
if they've changed the rules last time i
checked
so the whole idea is save up a thousand
pounds a year
how long's that gonna take and then they
say right now you've got it in the
lifetime monster
we'll we'll we'll give you a little
bonus but you have to buy a house to
live in you can't buy a house to rent
out
but the whole thing is designed for you
to be slow everything takes
time everything's slow
doesn't have to be that way does not
have to be that way in my world
everything's fast
so these schemes are created for poor
people to make poor people poorer and to
get people wrapped up in the rat race
and being slaves to society's slaves to
the banks
wrapped up in bad debt i don't like them
i'm out i'm a self-made millionaire
started from nothing was working class
now i'm a developer now i'm an investor
i'm worth several million and that's
just my opinion
but you do your own due diligence you do
your own diligence it's
in my opinion it's all sham so correct
store your own money
do not rely on the government for
anything right now store
your own money and then invest it
smartly into property invest it
smartly into financial education and do
not rely on the government for these
schemes because they are
nearly always not good in my opinion
max seaman do you reckon hmos are a
risky investment i found numerous
options for hms however feel it may be
difficult and a risky to
run max hmos are much better for cash
flow they're going to give you more cash
flow because instead of renting a
property
to one person you're going to rent a
property out to multiple people so
you're going to get more cash flow
the risk involved every investment's
risky you just need to do your due
diligence to de-risk it
the management side of it you need to
make sure you've got a good management
company in place you need to make sure
you know the market
you need to make sure that you don't try
and mix students with professionals with
benefit tenants
you know your market you have a good
product and you're going to get a lot
more cash flow with a hmo but you need
to know what you're doing
recently i went to a property agent from
work experience but i'm a little scared
i don't know why can you tell me
something i can overcome from fear of
wasting time
um sham listen we all get scared
okay and it's good that you're scared
because if you're scared if you're
trying to get work experience from
estate agents and you're going in and
you're feeling afraid
afraid of rejection afraid of looking
stupid afraid of saying the wrong thing
if you're not getting scared that means
you're not stepping out of your comfort
zone if you're not stepping out of your
comfort zone that means you're not
growing and if you're not growing that
means that you're dying so what i would
say is feel the fear and do it anyway
just do it most people underestimate
their own intelligence and overestimate
everybody else's
you know you'll be thinking i'm gonna
walk you through this stage they're
gonna think i'm stupid and
listen listen they're just people
they're just humans they've probably
only been working there three weeks
themselves they're probably scared
themselves you walk in and they're
probably scared of you
you know so just relax do what needs to
be done
and uh believe in yourself and if you
don't believe in yourself let me believe
in you
on your behalf because i do believe in
you okay so keep kicking ass
imran can you give me the top five
things required for b-r-r-r
where does one start would appreciate
your guidance so brr is buy refurbished
refinance rent it's a strategy where you
buy a property push the value up and
then you refinance you pull the money
out you recycle your cash
uh top five things i mean first thing is
is is getting good people around you
you need a power team you need an
environment you need a good environment
because if you're in a bad environment
if you're hanging around losers if you
haven't got a team
you're going to fail so get good team
around you get good advisors
second thing that i would say is i mean
for brr you've got to know the purchase
price you've got to know the re
development cost and you've got to know
the gdv so
that's it you need to figure out how can
you buy houses cheap how can you do them
up
cheap and then how can you refinance
high so that
if you can master those three things
with a good team around you
that's all you need that's four things
five things belief believe you can do it
if you think you can if you think you
can't you're probably right
all right tim franklin i've got three
hundred thousand pounds says
tim married currently unemployed and
going to live in london moving back from
los angeles
i'm eager to build a portfolio where
should i start should i buy a house for
myself and turn it into a rental
property as the first
property in my portfolio yeah man do
that buy a house yourself
live in it yourself but buy it buy a
property that needs a lot of work doing
to it
fix it up and then sell it i don't know
you know if you do that you don't pay
any tax
you buy a house you live in it you do it
up and you sell it you pay no capital
gains tax whatsoever because you lived
in it
so i don't know it depends on what you
want depends on what your end goal is do
you want to build wealth or do you want
cash flow
um my advice would be out of that 300
000 pounds but at least
at least 3 000 pounds that's one percent
one percent towards education
because your 99 of the money is going to
go a lot further if you invest just one
percent in yourself that'll be my advice
mk um got 40 000 pounds should i buy a
hmo or two
flats and do airbnb um
they're both good options if you buy two
flats to do airbnb make sure that you
have a good exit strategy
and you need to make sure that it would
stack up as flat on ast contracts
not just airbnb because airbnb the
service accommodation market may become
regulated one day
so make sure you've got a plan b um but
yeah i think either would be good
either would be good sophie says can you
explain exactly what refinancing is
the steps the pros the cons i feel like
refinancing is a word thrown about a lot
very easily but i don't understand
at all how it works so refinancing is
just getting a mortgage on a property
um so a refinance a remortgage is is
taking a mortgage on a property that you
already own
so if you own a property already and
then you want to get on a mortgage on it
you're gonna get you're gonna
re-mortgage the house because you've
already bought the house you might
already have a mortgage on it
so you're getting a new mortgage a
refinance and then you're going to use
that money to pay off the old mortgage
or you might have no mortgage you might
own the ca the house out right in cash
and then you're going to take a you're
going to get a loan against that
property
a lender is going to come give you money
they're going to use the properties
collateral they're going to have a first
charge on the property and that is
called
a refinance or a remortgage uh that is
what it means so now you can ban it
around yourself knowing
exactly what it means hey if you enjoyed
the video smash like
if you've got questions comment below if
i'm answering a question and that's
leading to another question
comment that question below i'm going to
be answering your questions next week
okay um 40 40 shorty
when buying buy to let or hmo do i need
to furnish the house with beds chests of
drawers and wardrobes
so if it's a hmo you will need to
furnish the house
if it's not a hmo you will not need to
furnish the house you don't have to
there's no rule you can do whatever you
want it's your house but
traditionally a hmo you will expect it
to be furnished
and wardrobes gesture drills beds yes
a single let don't furnish it and the
reason don't furnish it is because if
it's a single lap
usually people want to bring their own
furniture anyway and if you furnish it
and then the furniture breaks you're
responsible for it and it just becomes a
nightmare so
empty if it's a single let generally
speaking furnished if it's a hmo
um alain steele says what type of house
is generally best for a buy to let
detached semi-detached or terrorist
would this differ
for student young professional hmos or
single-family homes um listen there's no
absolute
right or wrong generally speaking
terrorists are better because
if you're buying a house to live in if
you're buying a house
you probably might want a detached house
you know or a semi-detached house you're
probably not going to want to buy
a terraced house to live in unless you
can't afford to do any better
so rent a house it's not really so much
the case because the rental
is short term so the rental difference
between a terrorist
and a detached is not massively
different but the value is massively
different
so you want to buy low terrorist rent
high with a property manager nearby
that's my opponent
so terrace tends to give better return
on investment generally speaking but
there's no hard and fast
rule daniel how do you set up a business
so you can stick the properties in the
business for tax
reasons there are tax advantages to
having a limited company set up you can
set up a limited company on companies
house and you can do it within 24 hours
very easy costs about 15 pounds and you
can do it yourself or
you can pay an accountant to do it but
don't pay them more than about 100 150
pounds to do it because
it would be a rip off if you paid more
than that dave oliver i live with my
family and i'm saving a lot
because the rent i pay here is a small
in comparison to buying or renting my
own place
i'm tempted to move out and get my own
place again asap
but i know it will be easier and wiser
to stay with my family for a few more
years so i can afford to invest more
should i stay with my family or invest
or
get my own place again and be skint
getting your own place and being skint
kind of sucks
it does make financial sense to stay
with your family as long as you can
the only thing i would say is i think
environment is really important so if
your family are negative people
or if your family are clamping your
style as an entrepreneur
i would rather live in a crummy little
flat on my own
because the environment's better and
it's my space so i would say live at
home
unless you think that it's gonna it's
gonna serve you better as a business
person or a property investor if you've
got your own space
jamie jamie says hey samuel here's my
question i've been watching the videos
the last few months i really like my
lower end high method i'm from
buckinghamshire oh
very posh so prices are quite high
the idea of buying a place in liverpool
and giving it to a laying agent is quite
daunting what advice do you have thanks
jamie
jamie what i'll say is the reason it's
daunting buying a place in liverpool is
because you don't know liverpool
financially it makes sense house prices
are very low house prices are rising
like crazy
rents are decent the return on
investments are good you
know buckinghamshire so buying outside
an hour you don't know is risky even
though it
financially makes sense so my advice
would be get to know liverpool
go there view houses there sit and have
coffee with investors and estate agents
and latin agents and builders and
structural engineers and architects and
get to know the area
get to know the properties in the area
and when you know the area well
then you want to start investing there
don't invest in an area you don't know
josh how do you go about deal sourcing
and making sure you don't give them the
deal and they don't
pay you for the deal okay well if you
give them the deal
and then they don't pay you that's
because you didn't ask for payment
upfront
always get payment upfront always get
payment up front for a deal
give them a calling off period to then
look over the deal but you got to take
payment upfront otherwise
it's never going to happen helping hands
i love this guy
thank you even though he did not answer
my question very informative video
what was your question helping hands uh
kris kringle commented underneath that
read my comments please dude he's a
scammer
what you're talking about is the very
skill that makes this man money
wow this sounds like a haitian a hater
he paints a picture and puts
you in it google samuel is exposed and
thank me later
yeah guaranteed that guy that wrote that
is
broke um listen listen listen
you just need to just listen to my
content and if you think something
sounds scammy or not good then ignore it
and if you think something sounds
helpful and good
then apply it that's it i am whatever
you want me to be
uh but guaranteed this dude is
absolutely broke all right next
sam hawkins sam hawkins respect you were
in my house recently and we were talking
over lunch
he says thanks for answering my question
last week you're so welcome i understand
that lease options is a numbers game in
terms of how many letters you send is
there any other method you would use to
find a lead
rather than the letters sam letters are
really good
um you can go on gumtree go on gumtree
and just see the landlords direct if
you're advertising your house on country
you're kind of
kind of desperate right call them up hey
you got your house on the market for 100
grand um
what's the value 100 grand okay how
about this i'll buy i'll buy you i'll
buy it off you for 100 grand
i'll pay you your um your price but on
my terms which is in seven years time
however right now i'll take on the
mortgage payments i'll become the
landlord how does that sound
but you can literally bring people from
gumtree from spare room from open rent
there's so many ways you've got to do
everything
don't rely on one strategy or one um
form of getting deals getting leads
estate agents off more off market deals
flyers um
software sites like just do everything
hope that helps sam you're a rock star
sam and chris cringle commented sam
under your comment
google samuel leaves exposed and thanked
me later dude you're a loser
i mean geez i'm taking so much headspace
up in your head you should i
i mean geez like anyway if you see if
you bother if you see real losers
in the comments um just have fun with
them maybe drop a comment have fun with
them because
geez i haven't got time i really wish i
did okay last question last question
last question
emma j i will be receiving 250 000
pounds inheritance soon
i'm currently renting my home i want to
quit my job soon i want an income to
replace my job
what would you recommend uh emma great
question listen if you've got 250
000 pounds i would recommend recycling
that money you want to use that money
you want to put it into a deal don't
just put it into a deal and try and get
the highest return on investment
put it into a deal and structure it
whereby you can put it in
and then later you can pull it out okay
and again this is this is what brr is so
you're going to put the money down
maybe buy use the 250 to buy a project
maybe it may be i don't know
an old pub or something turn it into
apartments use a bridging finance on top
of your 250 but then you've pushed the
value up
because now you've maybe got commercial
valuation or maybe now because you've
got luxury apartments you can split the
titles you push the value up
then you're going to refinance refinance
then i'm abandoning it around i'm
banning around we finance on the new
value
and pull back out your 250 leaving you
with a
leveraged property which is giving you
cash flow different flats but you've got
your money back you can do it again
this is this is this is fundamentally
what it's about and listen folks
you know this is the four things you
need to succeed you need knowledge
you've got to have the knowledge to
understand how to do that
and for some reason some people call me
a scammer because i offer training
courses
i mean geez does that mean universities
are all scammers does that mean
college is a scam does that mean it's
just i don't understand it it's kind of
crazy
but knowledge you need because the more
you learn the more you earn so you need
knowledge
you can get it you can get it from
someone else you can get it for free you
can pay me if you want you wanna do some
training that's cool but you got to get
knowledge somehow
next you got to take massive action you
can get all the knowledge but if you
don't take massive action nothing's
going to happen
next you need to believe in yourself
that troll guy
he doesn't believe in himself he's quit
on his dreams and now he's trying to
ruin everybody else's
so you need to believe you can do it and
then fourthly is you need persistence
and creativity
because you are going to hit walls in
this business you're going to have
challenges
you're going to get rejected you're
going to feel stupid you're going to
have down valuations
you're going to have problems but you
need to keep going and you need to find
a solution any idiot can find a problem
you need to find a solution
so that's what you need to succeed be
positive
take action get knowledge i hope you
enjoyed this video if you did
smash a like if you didn't smash a
dislike drop a question below i'll
answer you next week thanks for watching
i'll see you next time